foreign
[Music]
you know who Julius Francis is Julius
Francis yeah yeah third uh Caesar of
Rome
it's very good Julius Francis did you
just say a painter I I was with uh Ryan
on this one was also a painter sorry I
thought it was a [ __ ] drink shop a
famous artiste Orange Julius
Julius Caesar no orange juice have you
heard of that it used to be in all the
malls and it was like an orange whip
cream drink like creamsicle drink wait
you really don't know Orange Julius
I thought that was a nationwide thing I
know Jamba Juice
do you know what Jamba Juice is do you
know uh do you know Dairy Queen yeah but
I've never been to it okay Dairy Queen
and orange julius would sometimes be
tandem yeah they got this new thing a
dirty Queen now and I only know because
I go back to Florida Vegas all the time
and I'm about to do these Road stops and
[ __ ] because you could tell this guy's
on a diet dude he's like no no no so uh
when they make their Blizzard or
whatever the [ __ ] they have to hand it
to you across the counter upside down
why I guess to show you how [ __ ]
thick it is or whatever dude what the
[ __ ] you're like don't drop my drink
they always do it they don't do it
enthusiastically like the commercials
it's not like the Turkish ice cream guy
that keeps taking it
strawberry Frosty at Wendy's new flavor
new flavor fire or what I don't know
come on I don't know
it's Julius Francis not the third Caesar
the WNBA player she's a model sounds
like a WNBA player Julius Francis is a
guy it's a dude okay fine I'm not gonna
say anything what a guy in the WNBA all
right Joanna man one more guess you want
a Man's real name yes who is Julius
Julian Francis he's an Italian guy that
sells meatball subscribe
has recently gone viral wow he is an
ex-boxer who fought Mike Tyson in 2000.
oh that guy [ __ ] you I love him from the
WNBA exactly he's my hero okay he now
works as a security guard at box Park
Wembley and was filmed knocking out a
Rowdy visitor with just a single punch
makes sense for fun we got it we gotta
see this it makes sense he's probably a
big guy I mean you're a pro boxer that
fought Mike Tyson every other human
being must feel like a [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] like a cute Labrador we're getting
through an ad right now but this video
has gone viral and so he wanted to dress
like kind of quote unquote what went
down just to make sure he hates that
loud mouth guy that thinks he could
fight all the time oh it's the worst
I've seen this I thought they were in
London this is Julius yeah Julie oh
you'll see you'll see that they're in
London right yeah that is UK huh well
press play
and then taboo
the biggest dude the guy trying not to
be
so look at how nonchalant he just walks
no no
no
he's a big boy
who knows he just keeps walking he's
hunting him he's in the back no he goes
back around yeah this guy's talking [ __ ]
is doing oh he starts
walking around he's back here
see you later buddy
and he was being nice when he threw that
shot
by the way
that other Conor guy how he changes his
whole like tone yeah
that's not funny no he got to set the
precedent that what like what kind of
store was that like a [ __ ] shoe store
is it no wasn't it security guard at
Wembley Stadium oh box Park Wembley yeah
because it's like it looked like you
were at a [ __ ] Foot Locker or
something like a shoe release yeah I
named Melrose so uh so he intervened uh
with the dude in the Blue Rag uh and uh
knocked him out obviously in the viral
footage that man was shouting I hope you
have a heart attack you fat and then
it's blurred out as well as pushing a
member of the staff and despite attempts
to remove the Rowdy customer from the
area 57 year old ex fighter opted to
knock him out with the right hook hell
yeah
planes quote I was arrested and rightly
so I was taken to the police station for
about four and a half hours they came
back and said quote no further action
manager people at the door and they
looked at our CCTV I wasn't worried so
much about that because it was actually
me defending myself I had the right to
defend myself to Russia and that's what
I did when he raised the tank he lunged
yeah he lunged imagine if afterwards the
police and he wasn't accessible
autographs I mean actually
so uh Metro Police launched an
investigation but I've sent uh since
said that it has been dropped however
Francis has admitted that his license
has been temporarily suspended by the
UK's security industry Authority the
security license or boxes
why would they isn't that his job
investigation or something I guess how
it's supposed to work yeah slap on her
wrist it aren't security guards supposed
to secure so because because he needs to
work he says so I'm just trying to get
that sorted and then hopefully I'll be
back in the doors as soon as possible
you know get back to work but in the
meantime he says he wouldn't mind a
rematch with Iron Mike Tyson that's gone
viral and now he's like relevant again
he's just like hey I wouldn't mind if
there's a promoter that's willing to
promote a sanctioned fight and I never
have liked talking about money but if
they could come up with a decent offer
then who knows that means cool because
he's retired and doing a security job
that means he's not nowhere near close
where Tyson is and Tyson kill him the
first time though is he one of like the
one I think that just died or is that
like what year this what year was it two
two thousand no that's that was near the
later the Late Late yeah that was that
that was post Holyfield post earbud yeah
post holy holy photos when I was like in
junior high I think that's when he went
downhill field was like 98 yeah yeah
that was Bill Clinton yeah 90s was
Tyson's like [ __ ] crazy so it was uh
Francis was selected as the opponent for
Mike Tyson's UK debut and he famously
got the soles of his boots sponsored as
uh blah blah that was Francis
uh fought with other high profile boxes
such as Vitale uh Klitschko roots and
oddly Harrison he's on top yeah he's a
top rankings top right ranking boxer it
doesn't say who won he doesn't have like
a boxing school or there it is damn I
mean that's kind of what happens to some
athletes though right they just got to
go back to the regular especially boxing
especially it says Tyson would dominate
the fight gaining five knockdowns over
Francis in a span of four minutes
I can't believe they [ __ ] let that
happen [ __ ] destroy the first
knockdown came within 45 seconds usually
they have like a three knock down rule
per round for 45 seconds left in the
first round after being backed in the
ropes Francis attempted to throw a right
hand but the attempt missed the Tyson
landed a right uppercut
signature Francis remained under the
knees before finally getting back up in
the count of nine Tyson responded by
throwing three consecutive power punches
in an attempt to gain The Knockout
Victory but the punch is missed and
Francis quickly clinched with uh with
Tyson in an effort to slow Tyson down
watching Tyson fights really look like
you're watching something entirely
different yeah and also like the dudes
that he would fight they were bigger
because Tyson's big but they were bigger
yeah so well he's short he's short for
them it looked like David and Goliath
and then just him they just had they
just couldn't deal with his speed dude
his head movement his ability to close
the distance and then just uppercut you
into another mentioned dude everybody
was scared fighting him have you guys
seen his new like boxing program so like
him at 50 something moving around is
still scary as [ __ ] yeah dude also
memory man what the [ __ ] yeah muscle
memory even when he Bobs and weaves
you're like I try to do it and I like I
feel like I broke my spot I'm like ah he
loves the waves in like a different like
boxing style in general like Tyson has
his own [ __ ] like no but he looks
like the The Recoil bag when he Bobs
yeah that's what he literally looks like
like a human being
he's made some more like growing up in
the era where he was King it's like most
people only saw boxing when it was Tyson
yeah so that kind of [ __ ] you up for
any other fight you were just like this
is boring yeah do you remember that yeah
because all we would watch is Tyson back
then and then you see anyone else you're
like the [ __ ] is it because even like
holy feels really good but if you watch
his fights they're not as in any all the
heavyweight fights were too slow it
makes everyone look so defensive 30 on
on Holyfield about that oh like this
whole idea of like the shadow of being
the next champion after Tyson and the
notoriety I'm very thankful that uh my
parents richer friends uh were able to
get the pay-per-view for the Holyfield
Tyson fight and invited my parents over
and you saw the ear but the ear biting
everyone's storming the [ __ ] I
[ __ ] thought that was so weird but it
was so memorable like [ __ ] impossible
to forget he was all over TV I remember
they got the president's viewpoint on it
and [ __ ] what do you think about this oh
God who was was it Bill Clinton at the
time yeah I think so I just I just think
it's so sad that like the life pattern I
just wish Mike Tyson's life pattern
could have been better yeah because like
he he [ __ ] lost his license like so
early and he's like he just needed
earlier he also went to jail in his
prime I know that's what's sad it's like
[ __ ] man he was really good yeah but
like who knows what cool ass fights like
didn't happen you know yeah I think it
was because when he uh Paul versus Tyson
great
now
looking forward
I think I think he wanted to go full
clip yeah I think Mike Tyson would train
like he's never trained before and kill
him like he's never because even him
fighting Roy Jones Jr he was pulling
punches like crazy yeah he was going
yeah because it was an exhibition
matching yeah yeah there's no knock no
Knockouts I also have another one so
they can make money this I think he
would because it says it's a statement
piece it's like a pride piece because
here we think is the most you know
people who argue him or Muhammad Ali is
the two greatest whatever anyone else
whatever it's fine but like someone who
is literally never fought a professional
boxer in his life is Gonna Come fight
Mike Tyson yes
yeah yeah so Jake Paul come after him in
10 years
and silver see that's who he should go
out Anderson Silva's [ __ ] killing
himself on Jake Paul that's he's
Anderson Silva's boxing now bro yeah
he's been doing yeah everybody
Julio Cesar Chavez Jr and someone else
after that yeah
he knocked out Tito Ortiz I'm just
knocking everybody up but like after the
same size finally too because Jake Paul
finally like uh Tyron Woody's a little
shorter Ben astron's a little bit
smaller smaller in general yeah like
Anderson Silva and Jake Paul he's taller
he's never been muscular though yeah
that'd be actually the same he like
she's like 200 pounds yeah he's a big
dude yeah he's a big guy what's the
weight for uh light heavyweight like
weight class for boxing boxing I don't
know it's probably like 185 to like
190-ish heavier actually it might be
actually lighter because it's like then
there's Cruiser weight that's not like
closer to tour yeah boxing there's like
weight class every five like yeah yeah
five ten pounds it's smaller than
um MMA yeah it's completely different
yeah because I think heavy weighted in
mma's 200 in a month Anderson Silva
started in boxing and then went to MMA
and came back both like he was always
like a multi boxing and kickboxing but
like he he's actually boxed uh Julio
Cesar Chavez Jr is like a really legit
boxer yeah he's for real and he and he
was beating the chef how old how old is
he now he's like I'm just probably late
30s Anderson Silva something is 47.
Chavez his late 30s Anderson Silva's 47.
if you see I understand the way he moves
though he moves good man oh he always
moved well he was always snapped his leg
yeah yeah yeah yeah damn I hella
remember that Gumby's leg it makes my
butthole clinch everybody yeah that was
uh that was all right it went like less
than like 10 seconds he just checked the
kick terrible and then Chris Weidman
that happened to him recently happened
to him he the first kick he threw his
[ __ ] broke so it's like weird like he
did that to Anderson Silva and then he
did that to another guy that's why you
got to condition those shits crazy
that's what he can do there's nothing
preventative you got a shin condition
and then just place your low kicks
better you gotta get beat shins and
drink metal pipe milk like kick like
kickboxer exactly
except banana trees just like when my
dad sent me out to kick out kick the two
by four in her backyard that's why he
did that well I found out that later it
was just a marker for the septic tank
when it snowed but here I am as my
eight-year-old self trying to be Van
Damme kicking kicking a wooden plank in
our backyard that I thought my dad put
out there for me to train with cool wow
and then finding out when I was like 14
then
you ruined the septic tank I can't even
find the [ __ ] in this house
foreign